it's incredible how such a small piece
of material can cause
such a commotion but here in france
that's exactly what's happened
over plans by the retailer decathlon to
stock a sports version
of a hijab a muslim headscarf
[Music]
as well as an outpouring of twitter
outrage
several politicians have called for
boycott of decathlon
sport emancipates it does not submit
my choice as a woman and a citizen will
be to no longer trust a brand
that breaks with our values the french
health minister has
also waded into the debate
it's legal but it's a vision of women
that i do not share
i think it does not fit well with the
values of our country
france is a secular country with a hijab
as well as the christian cross
have been banished from state classrooms
and also from
government offices now religious symbols
aren't
outlawed and in fact they're a common
sight on the streets of france
but many argue that face and body
covering garments such as those worn by
muslim women
are seen as being a method to subjugate
them
but others including decathlon say such
items
make it easier for muslim women to take
part in activities
such as sports just
women should be able to wear whatever
they like forbidden the sale of this
clothing is just ridiculous
it shocked me that they had to cancel
the sales it's not an act of securism
it's not an act or will it go so far to
say islamophobic but it's very
anti-islamic
people should dress according to their
own tastes i don't think there's much
controversy about this issue
if women choose to wear it we must
respect it
so if she wants to wear it you know it's
her choice
but the backlash has been so big that
even decathlon staff
say they have been threatened our
customer service team has received
over 500 calls and emails since this
morning
our teams and our stores have been
insulted and threatened
sometimes physically before the product
even got out of the starting blocks the
force of the opposition saw decathlon
back down it will no longer sell a
sports hijab here
but it's a no-win situation for the
retailer which is also being criticized
for pandering
to collective hysteria that reveals the
level of islamophobia
here in france jolla diebinski
rt paris writer and online activist
omani al-qatat bay and patricia shanyon
from the french national front party are
there so on it too
we choose to cover up because it places
our body
on our terms independent of the male
gaze
it's necessary for us to have different
options available for different types of
women
that's the whole point is that
especially in industries like fashion
actually decathlon fully supported their
decision to put the hijab
on the the sport hijab on the french
market in their stores
it was only after there was a huge
public outcry
uh that they crawled back so
uh you know uh basically a dick and law
has no squibbles
a capitalist company they only wanna
make profits and they were forced
they were forced to take the hijab off
their shelves here in france
because of the huge pressure from the
public